[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the last bonus
show of 2017 we've got something special
at the end of the bonus show that maybe
people will like maybe they'll hate it
the so-called free speech keyboard
warriors are furious that Twitter's
purge has started they started it
earlier this week they are more
proactively getting rid of content and
users more importantly that they've
deemed to be hateful and violent a lot
of these users are advocates of white
separatism and white supremacy online
bullies it's not just right-wingers that
are being targeted but it's true that
because of the alt rights online
rhetoric there are probably going to be
a lot of alt writers who lose their
Twitter accounts as a result of this
although interestingly enough after
dispenser his account is still up oh
yeah suspected himself that it will be
taken down and he was tweeting that his
account might be taken down
let's wait though I don't know that all
of the accounts are getting taken down
immediately right this is now they've
enacted new policy it doesn't mean that
everybody gets blocked in the first 1 2
or 3 days but I think it will be
interesting to see that there of course
those who are completely clueless about
the First Amendment and they're saying
this is a violation of people's right to
free speech as provided by the
government the government has nothing to
do with this twitter has Terms of
Service they can use whatever standard
they want to determine what is
considered violent and hateful content
it is very different than blocking
people if Twitter if Twitter suspends
someone I consider that equivalent to
refusing service by a business right
that's what I think but not under you
know protecting status is grand well
right if Twitter decided we are not
going to allow gay people or black
people on our system mm-hmm that would
be a violation I believe of business
non-discrimination laws with with
homosexuality a sexual orientation it
would depend on whether the user is in a
state that includes sexual orientation
is a protected class that's not what
going what's going on here there is
no constitutional or legal protection
based on your political views based on
your racial views or anything like that
so I think that that argument is not a
good argument I think the more
interesting argument though is whether
this is good business for Twitter
Twitter advertising is a growing source
of revenue that exists for Twitter and
much like what we saw happened with
YouTube you can understand why Twitter
would not necessarily want a policy of
if it's not illegal we allow it because
that is going to lead understandably to
a lot of advertisers saying yeah I'm
just not sure about advertising on
Twitter so from a business perspective
in that sense it could be good but you
could have blowback from people who say
I don't like those terms of service I
don't like twitter deciding whether my
ideas and tweets are ok or not and maybe
people will abandon the platform I don't
know the answer to that yeah I
understand why they're doing it and
obviously the free speech arguments have
no merit to them yeah but I do find it
disappointing in a sense because these
sites like Twitter and YouTube start out
as a center for free speech and that
anyone can just upload or post whatever
they want
supposedly yeah I mean you can't make
threats against people obviously there's
going to be some limits but then they
become too corporate right all the
advertisers come in and have too much
influence over the users it just changes
the whole platform there's a name for
this in colloquial speech which is
selling out and it's not a term I
necessarily I think incorrectly applied
a lot of times but what you're basically
pointing out is the initial mission of
the platform becomes perverted by
becoming corporate and focusing more on
ad revenue or whatever type of revenue
then an open platform or whatever else
yeah and usually you'd say that about an
individual yeah whereas the business all
along was trying to make the most amount
of money that it could people sometimes
say the david pakman show has sold out
because we now have a few advertisers
and we have subscriptions or whatever
you know I think it's the Jenga tower on
camera 3 that's really where we sold out
yeah and that's thing that's gonna need
to go soon I think I've just been
leaving it on because it's kind of a you
know whatever it sits there with me will
you be leaving Twitter as a result of
this I'm barely on Twitter right I have
an account I think I have you know fewer
than 100 followers really I mean I
I don't post you often maybe I'll have
to get back into it you want to say what
your username is for people who want to
follow you now producer Pat Forde follow
me on Twitter producer Pat Forde all
right very good
narcan narcan also called naloxone is an
overdose antidote for opiate overdose
dose overdoses I actually saw this used
on someone when remember last year I'm
sure Pat remembers when I fainted on a
plane coming back from Italy right after
getting back I went to the emergency
room just to make sure that I didn't
have anything like acutely wrong and
then I went and checked in with my
regular doctor about it and when I was
at the emergency room at Mass General
Hospital
a woman was wheel-chaired in and she
clearly was close to an overdose I think
that you don't use the term overdose
unless the person actually dies from the
overdose but maybe we do have to die but
you don't have to die okay we'll listen
I would call it that she was overdosing
on what appeared to be heroin some kind
of opiate and she was brought into
triage and like you see everything
that's going on and she was talked to
and she could not keep her eyes open and
she was slunt slouched down and the
triage nurse said something like listen
and she was in an unknown entity it was
very clear everybody at the hospital in
New York said if you don't if you're not
able to tell me your name we're gonna
have to narcan you and there was a
discussion about that and eventually
they wheeled her around to some area
where she wasn't visible and all of a
sudden you hear like this incredibly
loud whoop type noise and she had been
narcan and apparently it does something
to you where it it counteracts I don't
know what officer doctor it counteracts
the effects of the opiates right and it
instead of like being a downer it
immediately brings you up and I guess
sometimes people react like that where
they immediately become loud and and
full of energy as soon as they are
narcan like it was yep it was a violent
thing I mean it was a violent reaction
it's like in the movie Pulp Fiction
where they give her a shot of it yeah
I'd only after she's overdosing on
heroin jock pops right up exactly right
so that's not what this story is about
the story is that there are police who
are not agreeing they are split
on whether police departments should
obtain maintain and track supplies of
narcan as well as trained police
officers on how to use it and the
there's basically two arguments one is
the financial argument which is it's not
necessarily cheap to do training and to
maintain a supply of unexpired narcan I
don't know what the what the expiration
time is on it and also to supply it to
all of our police officers that's one
argument the other argument is that this
is really we don't want to put police
police or first responders yes they are
trained first responders but we
shouldn't really put them in the
positions of making decisions better
suited to medical professionals whether
it's doctors or nurses and that for that
reason some police departments aren't
interested in the responsibility of
having police officers empowered to
determine whether they are going to narc
on someone or not the the counter to
that is by its very nature when you say
first responder oftentimes the police
person the police officer is the first
person to arrive when someone is
overdosing and timing is critical and
they may be the person best suited to
save somebody's life with narcan well
just to tackle that argument I don't
think it's too invasive to it's it's a
nasal spray and you're able to give it
to family members of those struggling
with addiction in the case that their
family member their loved one was to
overdose yeah so if you know just
average everyday citizens are able to do
it and they're clearly not medical
professionals in most of these cases
well but my abilities the liability
could be different now is it I thought
it was an injection also but it's a
nasal spray I thought nasal spray yeah
I'm aware of the nasal spray but I
thought that like medical professionals
often had the it was the shot okay
but yeah I know this I think it's a
worthy investment you know I talked if
if we believe that police officers can
be properly trained and empowered to
make decisions about all sorts of other
like potentially life-changing things
like should I use force here because
someone is putting me in danger should I
use deadly force against someone or not
then I think we can probably train
officers to know whether or not using
narcan is an order don't you think
yeah it's a concern in you know a
reasonable argument I guess I also heard
much worse ones including that it could
disincentivize people from trying to get
off of a heroin and addiction because
they know that if they were to overdose
then a police officer down the road
could come by and saved their lives and
I think that's just horrible
reasoning I don't think that's good
reasoning I don't think that's good
reasoning yeah so the debate continues
and more than likely I mean each
department can decide for themselves
what it is that they want to do right I
mean if you live in a community where
heroin overdoses aren't as significant
of a problem as they are say even around
here in New Hampshire and parts of New
England it's horrible yeah I do what's
going on it really is it's yellow and
Cape Cod is a nightmare in terms of
what's going on okay to go from a really
depressing story to something positive
to end the year on Pat long ago told me
that he is able to solve Rubik's cubes
very quickly and easily I am NOT I've
tried to learn how to solve a Rubik's
Cube and I'm able to get like one ones
one color all matched up so we thought
today I've never seen Pat do this let's
see if Pat is able to solve the Rubik's
Cube okay how did you learn to do this
oh when I was like I think twelve years
old there's a little booklet that came
in yep and I was just one of the people
that studied the booklets the ISTEP and
I took a few weeks before I mastered it
but I would never forgot how well I will
I will narrate to people what it is
that's going on and to begin with Pat
has it has been mixed up too I mean I
wanted you to mix it up to make sure
that there's no concerns about this I
can assure you this is my personal you
know tube yeah it's not been tampered
with in any way and it is fully
scrambled so Pat take it away and I will
sort of talk through what it is that's
going on all right here we go and you
should probably do they just keep doing
it you don't need the split screen now
let's keep it on pass so people can see
all right so we're starting with it
starting with a completely scrambled
cube Pat is starting to make moves I
can't yet describe anything coming
together other than a few white pieces
that are starting to all appear together
on one face
Pat is twisting twisting his hands are
slightly shaky and he's starting to
develop a bit of what looks like a cold
sweat but he is continuing to do it
white pieces continuing to align he's
holding it in a way where it's actually
kind of difficult to see
alignment but the white panel is all
completely set spinning spinning
spinning I'm starting to see some yellow
pieces on the same side I'm starting to
see some orange pieces line up and Pat
is continuing to go any stage-fright
over he's looking quite frantic in a way
like a panicked panicked Pat as we know
orange pieces lining up orange pieces
continuing to line up red pieces lining
up green increasingly aligned blue is
starting to look good it's getting is it
just me or is the rubik's cube becoming
louder and louder as we get close to I
think that's just me breathing close to
completion Pat becoming and cluttered
incredibly red in the face his arms are
tensing but really is getting very very
close
Wow I mean you're just how do you even
know what you're doing are these just
algorithms you know no no I'm just I'm
just doing it you know that's at a loss
for words right
orange is almost completely done yellow
is looking pretty good just a couple of
those pieces I've never had as a crazed
look on his face I said other time I saw
Pat look like this is when I brought him
vegan cheese wants to try and there it
is completely done I don't know how long
it took like two minutes that is
impressive
that is impressive I I was only able to
get so the booklet tells you first you
want to line up the white right and not
just to solve the white side you have to
get the whole layer done that's correct
yeah with the right pieces at the top so
how many different algorithms do you
need to know there's like a good eight
steps it's a yeah eight algorithms and
you just have to know how to orient the
queue yeah fun little hobby if you get
involved in it
now did you the the Rubik's Cube is
looking shiny did you grease it up with
vegetable oil no it's gonna say there's
no Lube in this you got to lube your
cube dad I gotta lube your cube because
that's why it almost fell apart now so
frantic and nervous I can't think of a
better note to end the year on then
you've got to lube your cube yes and on
that note thank you to everyone to all
of our new members 2017 has been a
record year I actually think that we had
more growth in 2017 okay we had in all
prior years combined
the show maybe now I don't even know
what I'm talking about but that's what I
read on the internet anyway thanks to
everybody though genuinely our patrons
our members are we making this bonus
show a free to all we're gonna make it
free for the public so just as a message
to people who are not yet members this
is the type of nonsense that we
occasionally do on the bonus show so
please sign up and maybe I will go into
training during the break and teach
myself how to fully solve the the
Rubik's Cube and maybe I could do it
when we get back yep by the end of 2018
I expect to see you do it blindfolded
what's the record for time for solving
ten seconds yeah ten mohs me out of the
water yeah this is echinus isn't that
impressive I tell you ten seconds from
totally scrambled something like that
yeah I don't even know how that's
physically possible because you met it
seemed like you made about a hundred and
fifty moves I know but they have
different algorithms different steps
uh-huh you know I'm not too advanced
with it I've been interested in a little
bit interested it's basically math right
that's what we're talking about yeah I'm
a complex method very powerful exactly
all right we will see you in 2018 the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]